il faut qu'il redevienne ce qu'il est
tout a changé on est le dernier espoir
de l'humanité c'est un des thèmes
préférés du cinéma science-fiction celui
des robots qui prennent le contrôle sur
les humains qui les domaines et les
années autistes mais depuis 6 mois avec
le développement de système
d'intelligence artificielle comme chaque
GPT qui peuvent improviser et discuter
avec des humains la réalité se rapproche
un peu trop rapidement de la fiction 10
un millier de spécialistes qui réclame
maintenant un moratoire de 6 mois sur ce
type de recherche
parmi les graines des signataires la
propagande et les fausses informations
l'automatisation systématique des
emplois et la prolifération d'esprit
non-humain plus intelligent que leur
créateurs comment ferais-tu la
différence entre le monde du rêve et le
monde réel bien sûr on est loin des
systèmes hyper sophistiqués à la mais
depuis le succès de tchat GPT tous les
géants comme Google Microsoft et
d'autres promettent de le surpasser en
puissance et en efficacité et encore
beaucoup de chemin à faire selon moi
pour atteindre le niveau d'intelligence
des humains mais on a passé l'équivalent
d'un test de Turing c'est à dire que les
gens qui interagissent avec ces systèmes
peuvent facilement penser que ils sont
en conversation avec un être humain les
signataires demandent donc aux
entreprises et au gouvernement de
prendre une pause pour réfléchir à la
façon d'encadrer ce champ d'activité en
explosion les six mois c'est un chiffre
comme on aurait pu en mettre un autre
mais c'est un bon chiffre ça permettra
effectivement de réunir des grandes des
des Colocs de réunir les chercheurs
d'avoir les pouvoirs publics qui
prennent position ils n'ont pas le temps
pour l'instant avec sa future charte
numérique du ministre champagne le
Canada serait déjà sur la bonne voie
tout un chapitre on sera le premier pays
au monde avec l'Union européenne a
encadré l'intelligence artificielle Open
et à un créateur de chat GPT prépare
déjà la troisième version de son robot
ici normand Grondin Radio-Canada
Montréal